>> Sally: I think this year's
iGEM competition is the best ever.
The project we just heard about was amazing!
>> Dude: And that bacterial
flotation device was totally cool!
It's the balloon-o-genesis
module I've been looking for.
I want to try it with my Bacterial Balloon idea.
I know it'll work.
>> Sally: I thought you were
done with Bacterial Balloons!
>> Dude: Sally, where's your curiosity?
We'll need to put the
flotation-thing-a-ma-gjiggy together
with the Gas-o-Matic module and this time
put some feedback program at the promoters
to make the devices stop...this
is SO going to work.
>> Sally: We can try to build it
when we get back to lab but some
of it looks like very specialized DNA.
First, we'll need a feedback
loop that works for Buddy.
Second, the flotation module
is more than 6000 base pairs.
Didn't that team say that it works
better if these two sections are removed?
Maybe we should directly synthesize the shorter
flotation part with a Buddy feedback loop,
then we can hook it up to the Gas-o-Matic
module we already have in the lab.
>> Dude: Now you're talking!
But I think I forgot how to directly synthesize
DNA...I mean we've done so many things
in the lab and I remember a lot of them but...
>> Sally: Dude, we don't synthesize it.
We get a company to do that for us.
>> Dude: Whew.
So do I copy down this picture
from the board and mail it to them?
>> Sally: You could but they
wouldn't know what to do with it.
We'll need to send them the exact DNA sequence,
and then they can string the Gs, As, Ts,
and Cs together in the right order.
Every DNA synthesis company
does it a little differently
but the chemistry is pretty standard.
It involves protection and
deprotection of a growing DNA chain
with specialized bases called
deoxynucleoside phosphoramidites.
>> Dude: Gesundheit!
Sorry. What's so special about them?
>> Sally: Only one base links to a DNA
chain at a time until you deprotect the end,
which then allows you to add
the next base in your sequence.
>> Dude: That sounds like a pain.
>> Sally: No, think about it.
All you have to do is attach your first base,
let's say a protected G, to some sort of polymer
or bead, and then when you deprotect the G
you can add a second base, how about an A?
Then when you deprotect that A, you can
add a third base, let's put a T there.
>> Dude: Ha!
even I know that won't work.
What if that A doesn't hook up?
Then you've got G-T instead of G-A-T.
What good is that?
>> Sally: Dude, you're smart, but so
are the chemists who worked on this.
There's one more step called
"capping" so that any deprotected base
that doesn't properly connect is
shut down and can't be added to.
Those shorter pieces of DNA can be
taken out of the mix at the very end.
>> Dude: But won't there be a
lot of mistakes to get rid of?
Even if capping works half the time, you'll
be getting rid of half your sequence,
then half of that half...you'll
have nothing left.
>> Sally: Luckily this construction
process is more like 99% efficient.
But even so, you can't build something as
long as this 6000 base pair flotation device.
Most companies build a bunch of shorter
oligo nucleotides, maybe 60 base pairs long,
and then use PCR to stitch them together.
>> Dude: and you trust them
to do all this right?
>> Sally: They verify the final DNA by
sequencing it before they send it to you.
Sometimes there are problems
at one stage or another
but DNA synthesis is getting faster
and less expensive every year.
>> Dude: Sally this is great!
With your credit card and my ideas, we
can write some DNA that's completely new.
Race you back to lab.
I want to get this DNA ordered today.